okay let's let's figure out how to
develop the skill for blending with
ballistics let's try this okay start
with fixated motion and his grip his
structure is helping me find the in
spaces in it okay so I'm not going like
this I am using his grip to blend so
that becomes effortless he's pushing and
I find my way around all of those
obstacles and get it to work
so if you look home home not like this
you see that difference
okay so boom body body the here is he's
pushing and you're gonna see the
difference do you see uh not it okay
boom so I'm in the way
you see I'm in the way and I'm going to
move out of the way watch my head that
starts here along goes around body body
moves inhale exhale okay let's try that
so let's look at this in terms of
architecture so you're you're seen a
kind of topsy-turvy effect on his body
right right okay so you're thinking spin
the propeller boom right
oh you're thinking pull him see that
those all require muscle why not let him
fall into that spot so here you go
you're cutting this or you're pulling
this and what you want to do instead is
just let him fall into that spot so some
of you are just way off because you're
cutting like this and that will not
translate into a ballistic parry the
kind of movie
formalistic as he throws a strike you're
going like that and that's not Aikido
then some of you are like okay I got
here and then you go I don't trust this
[Music]
and then now your performance envelope
goes down so instead once you get here
trust trust you're not doing anything
so martially right when I'm not pulling
him ooh I'm free to hit when I'm pulling
him you're checking yourself out at the
same time so here I got my angle
disturbance do you understand that's all
I want
boom I'm going to knock them I don't
care how he falls you understand you're
prioritizing Aikido like aesthetics
aesthetics you just knock the hell out
of them okay so you get tri your annual
disturbance and let it do its stay you
can see how relaxed don't go here and
then we'll get you very relaxed
so if you see there's none of this you
see none of this I'm not going for my
right to my left that hand went up right
this way around it yeah
different so here's where we're gonna
lose a lot more people who can who is
still afraid it's not going to be able
to help you in this so we might divide
up but katate dori is any kind of
training wheels for the art that's why
we spend a lot of time on it you can
learn a lot of the skill sets but
they're a little more distant from all
the applications okay so we also have
continuity right and like katate dori
it's a fixated movement and I use my
fixated movements to help me get to my
ballistics
so the ballistic equivalent of
continuity continuity shoulder drop is
yokomenuchi Oh boom okay or any
ballistic strike coming on a horizontal
plane you understand so katate dori is
kind of the master of fixated
cockadoodie is a fixated equivalent to
yokomen but the oklahoman is a kind of
master plan for all horizontal plane
traversing so as he goes to Latorre
I have to do the same thing so here it's
right it's fixated and now I don't let
him grab me but I'm doing this same
exact blendy I'm not gonna go let's do
this side I'm not gonna go like that
you see I'm blending around it just like
swords connecting and he goes past me
just like always all connection begins
before he actually extends out to you so
I stay connected and you're going to see
you can't do this and friend his elbow
like these scaredy-cat because we're
doing to use as a rolling pivot point
okay go I'm fine
okay let's try it
hi so this is the hard part of your own
practice and this is the hard part of
all the weapon arts that's why this is
what's popular nowadays Hey so you have
a dabbler culture that I'm trained
enough let's take the weapons up and
we'll just do this so he does the
horizontal right okay
but if it's a knife you're fun okay so
it's not a free-for-all there's a couple
of things you have to understand when we
did Catoctin you've been told a million
times connection is prior to you
remember that
but you always train like this after the
fact now the thing is moving at you and
now you you can't do that for ballistic
so connection is already here it's
already here he goes you see how I'm
moving watch when he most try to watch
when he moves you move whenever you want
right
[Music]
can you see that he goes you see that
difference so I have to develop that
skill I have to develop the skill of
connection without contact got it and I
can only develop the skill by countless
reps reps reps reps over and over and
over so we can go slow and iMovie then
start to pay attention I'm not only
moving when he moves not after he moves
when he moves but my first movement if
you ask yourself is it towards him
towards me not towards anything go
towards him not like this look at the
different oh my god is scary as hell to
my body okay so he goes and I'm moving
towards him but Virginia I'm not moving
toward town I'm blending with him so he
moves and hope reach so it'll help if I
stay
okay third point let's look go back to
this I don't want to hang out on the
wrist
he comes here I'm not on the wrist look
where I'm at you see right here below
his elbow wrist too much slapping the
shoulder inside the elbow above it
doesn't work right below it that's where
my arm fits you see it's not a
free-for-all
so I can't go like this
I can't start there then leave it easy
keep that connection point chief that
connection point but in that reconciling
way I'm still going around it I'm just
laying my sword on his sword okay let's
show ya I'll make them make the point
again so as he comes in right I am going
for that part on his arm can you roll
your sleeve up yes so this part right
there okay this basic thing when you're
on the inside of the arm you're below
the elbow when you're on the outside of
the arm go above the elbow so outside of
the arm tricep tendon of insertion right
there below the arm you take that same
inch and you're right here so you're not
here you're not here you're not here
okay so he comes in right and I find
that spot when I find that spot it's not
that I'm cutting down and shoving it
down I'm doing this same thing kentuc
Ted I'm doing the same feeling of katate
where I'm going around the contact
points you understand so he goes with
this I'm still there and I'm going
around that I'm just laying my sword on
top of his not cutting down around I
keep that so if he when he falls really
fast bomb has to stay up with him
do you understand I don't let go like
this and then oh you're gonna lose
contact so I go
[Music]
okay let's go